very unsettling all right joe thank you  so let's get you up to date now on the  latest coronavirus numbers first across  the state  there are now more than 76 thousand  confirmed cases  more than 500 cases were added to that  total  just overnight now though our daily case  rate has been dropping today that number  was the largest spike we've seen since  the beginning of the month  the death rate though continues to  decline now 10 people  10 lives lost overnight clark county now  responsible for the majority of those  state cases  there are nearly 65 000 cases and more  than 1 300 deaths  however the recovery rate does remain  quite high at 92.5 percent